yes brother good evening
doctor I've been coming regularly to
your peace TV conferences for l so many
years my question is I'm in a situation
of two families both are Muslim families
I know the boy I know the girl the
families I have been the media
coordinator of those boy and girl and
they are going to get married so can
non-muslim be a witness of the agreeing
family and the boy and
girl to the
nikah brother asked a very good question
that he has two friends both are Muslims
one from the girl side one from the boys
side he's the mediator he knows both of
them and he got them together can he be
a witness to the marriage of as they are
telling me to be the witness as they
tell to be the witness can you be you
can be
under one condition
only condition is applied if you bear
witness that there's no God but Allah
and Prophet Muhammad is a messenger you
can even be a witness to the nikah thank
you hope that answer the question thank
you brother this question is from a
non-muslim sister she's present in the
audience but for security reasons she
will not like to come on the microphone
I'll be reading a
question if a non-muslim girl wants to
marry a Muslim boy and the Muslim boy
asks the girl to convert not by force
but because he wishes her to accept the
religion is it wrong meaning is it wrong
on the part of the boy to ask to convert
secondly if a non-muslim girl marries a
Muslim boy without converting but still
follows the Islamic religion as it is
supposed to be followed is it wrong on
the part of the girl to follow the
religion but without converting her name
is kushbu she's is a teacher by
profession ask the question that a
non-muslim to ask a question that can a
non-muslim girl if she wants to marry a
Muslim boy and the Muslim boy request
her to accept Islam is it right and if a
non-muslim girl follows Islam without
converting is it
acceptable the Quran says in Surah Bak
chapter number 2 verse number 221 that
do not marry unbelieving
woman until the belief do not marry a
mushika until they believe because it
further says that it is preferable to
marry a believing woman even if she's a
Bond woman even if she may be a servant
even if she may be ugly it is far
superior to marry a believing woman
who's a Bond woman rather than
unbelieving woman even if she attracts
you she may be the most beautiful woman
she may be a beauty queen she may be the
wealthiest woman but a believing woman
is far superior so in terms of is it
right for a Muslim man to ask the
non-muslim woman to convert before
marrying it is not right it is a must
without she accepting Islam he cannot
marry her why I'll tell you for example
if I tell you that there's a car one TI
is of a cycle and the other is of a
tractor will the car run no all the
tires should either be off a bicycle
you'll have a hand cut at
least or of a tractor you'll have a
proper tractor because when you're
leading a life the views and
philosophies
the major thing the goal of jna should
be same coming to a second question that
if a woman follows the teachings of
Islam but does not convert is it
acceptable see for conversion you don't
have to publicly announce you don't have
to come on the microphone and say I bear
witness that there's no God but Allah
it's not a must if you feel your life is
in danger if you say within your heart
and tell it to almighty God you don't
even require any
witness it's between you and Allah
so there is no particular ceremony that
is required but proclaiming is
preferable so that the people in the
world don't misunderstand you but if you
feel your life is in danger if you
Proclaim to Allah only and keep it in
your heart and follow alhamdulillah
following is more important than
proclaiming it is preferable for the
lady not to mention but yet follow Islam
than to mention she has converted and
not follow
Islam have you heard my answer it is
preferable for a non-muslim woman to
practice Islam without proclaiming
rather than Proclaim and not practice
Islam practicing is more important than
proclaiming it's between her and Allah
so the moment she starts practicing
Islam it's understood when she offers
Salah she agrees there is one Allah and
Prophet Muhammad is a messenger the
moment you say
a it is in that you believe that there
is no God but Allah and Prophet Muhammad
is the messenger finish so if he starts
practicing she doesn't have to Proclaim
also so if she wants to do the second
practicing is more important than
proclaiming but if she wants to Proclaim
it is fine she can Proclaim hope that
answer the
question yes
brother har Krishna here I'm looking I
came here first time uh people are very
eager to know about his life uh woman
and man but this discussion uh you think
this discussion will really solve our
real problem of Life birth head old and
disease and death that we are suffering
from birth old AG death and disease that
will uh real this problem will solve in
our life to married with some nice woman
or wealthy woman or good relationship
with woman brother as the question we
have come here to discuss about men and
women's rights marriage will it solve a
problem of diseases some problem it will
solve if you marry a woman you have less
chance you real problem of life is
brother you ask the question let me give
the reply you as the question we are
discussing about men and women and life
and marry will it solve the problem of
diseases Etc
brother are you listening to me you're
looking then listening here very good so
it will solve some of your problem of
disease if you marry a woman you like
inshallah you won't go to outside so
less chance of having STD sexually
transmitted diseases less chance of
having
so if you marry correctly it will solve
some of your problem of disease not all
fine but this session is talking about
women's rights so we have different
lectures and different sessions talking
about different solution for Humanity
today is the solution for the women's
rights you come from my last
lecture purpose of life that will get a
real solution to life so I've kept that
in Waiting you know final round you know
the best is always last
correct this is my first talk then I'm
going to come on Friday again give a
talk on Al Quran should have the
understanding then Saturday open
question answer session last day final
purpose of our life if you come for that
inshallah most of your questions of life
will be answered hope that answer the
question okay har
Krishna any non-muslim lady uh but we
have a reverse sister so if the chair
person permits could we allow her okay
okay we'd allow that
asalam alaikum my name is Mariam Sharif
I am from Ireland and a physical
therapist by profession alhamdulillah I
got a chance to be accept Islam but my
question is my father never got the
chance and Sherk is the biggest sin and
I want to know if there is a specific
Dua or something I can read on his names
so that his sin will be
forgiven s has a question that
alhamdulillah she has accepted Islam and
she says that unfortunately her father
he died as a mushrik so can I read any
Dua anything in his name so that sin can
be forgiven sister of the Quran says in
Surah chter number 4 vers number 48
Surah n number 4 ver 116 that if Allah
pleases he may forgive any sin but the
sin of shik he will never
forgive because a person who has done
shik has committed the most Hest sin so
if the person doing shik and before he
dies if he repents inshallah Allah will
forgive but if he dies as a
mush he is
destined for H there's no other option
and this is also narrated in the Quran
when ibraim
Alam Prophet Ibrahim when he
prays for father who was a mushh then
the verse was revealed that when the
person is alive you can ask Allah to
give hiah to your parents to your father
to your mother to your brother may Allah
guide them to the straight path but if
they die as a mush and if you know that
as a mush you cannot pray for them you
can only pray that oh my God oh my Lord
Allah make for my offsprings Muslims who
will submit the will to Allah and this
is the Dua of ibraim alam his father
also was a mush but he does the Dua inim
chapter number 14 the last few verses he
prays that make my
offsprings those who would submit the
will to Allah who would be Muslims and
we find that both his children
Isham
andam both of them became messengers of
Allah subhana tala so what I request to
you sister you make a to Allah subhana
ta'ala that may your offsprings be the
ones who will submit the will to Allah
and be on the straight path hope that
anwers the
question yes
brother my name ISAT and I'm a student
before starting sir first of all I would
like to thank you because are they any
the non-muslims are they any other
non-muslim like to ask a question
they're most welcome to come on the
microphone any non-muslim like to ask a
question whether from The Gents or from
the sisters this is the opportunity any
questions on the topic women's rights in
Islam or any questions on Islam and
compared religion this is the
opportunity and non-muslim like to ask a
question they're most
welcome if not we allow the Muslims but
in between if they feel they can come on
the microphone and they can jump the
queue that the
perogative yes brother yeah first of all
sir I would like to thank you because uh
uh
I have become a better human being and
not only a better human being but a
better Muslim because of you and
undoubtedly it is Allah who provides the
heed but for me you were the source of
that
heed and my question is that uh I have
read in glorious Quran that in previous
time during the time of prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam men were
allowed to keep female slaves and uh
they were allowed to have that intimate
relationships with them without the ncah
and the offsprings were also considered
to be
legitimate so I mean wasn't it a any
kind of degradation of the honor of the
women and were women allowed to do that
or this privilege was only confined to
men brother as a question that at the
time of the Prophet there were women who
were slave women and you allowed to have
sex with them even without marrying so
why was it allowed what is the privilege
and is the vice versa permitted on there
are many vers in the Quran we say that
that you can have sex with whom those
are who your wife and what your right
hand possesses right hand possesses
means they were the slaves and at the
time of the Prophet the walls used to
take place and when walls used to take
place they were captives when they were
captive from both the sides the men and
the women they became
slaves though if you analyze there are
vers in the Quran which also says in
Surah chapter number four number 25 if
you do not have the means to get
married then marry a slave woman and
give her freedom in M that if you don't
have the means to get married so marry a
slave woman and give her her Freedom as
Mah so here it's encouraging that
although the slavery has been
abolished brother you asked a question
your question is over it is correlated
actually you cannot go anything you have
to go behind the que to correlate you
ask the question we heard your question
it was wrong if we start correlating
always non-muslims allow Muslims they
can go be the queue no problem if we
start coring we'll be able to handle
very few questions for non-muslim I'm a
bit
lent so now the thing is that so it's
preferable to marry vice versa it's not
possible it is only for the female women
slaves that the man can have sex the
Quran doesn't say the vice versa and
this again if if you analyze that if you
see at that time promiscuity was very
common promiscuity and having sex
outside the bond very common so Islam
has bought it in stages like as alcohol
was very common the first verse of the
Quran of Surah Bak chapter 2 vers number
219 says that in alcohol there is
prophet and loss loss is more than
Prophet the next verse was revealed in
Sur n 4: 43 that do not pray with your
mind befogged mean when you're praying
don't have intoxicant finally the ban
came in Sur ma 5 vers number 90 that
alcohol is Ban so here first almighty
God Allah subhana tala prohibits any
other sex only two people allowed your
wives and that which your right hand
possesses now in this age we don't have
you know any walls it may take place
people say that the Quran talks about
slavery is it Justified I said yes why
not you know why
because today we know that
internationally slavery has been banned
but do you know what's happening in
Guantanamo
B you know the laws of UN
resolution how they treat the prisoners
of War if you compare that with the
Islamic law Islamic law is far superior
to what's happening in
Guantanamo and after a few days we have
a speaker coming by the name of James E
he's a Chinese and he was put in
Guantanamo he will give you story so do
attend that talk so if you see what is
done in
Guantanamo and the way the prisoners of
War are ill treated you know they're
imprisoned in the Islamic law the slave
is free to move around imagine pris of
War but free to move around
great major thing you're giving them a
place to walk they can go to the they
cannot run away but if they run what
going to do you have to catch up with
them
but imagine a prisoner of war is not
chained in the normal prisoner of war
you have prison camps with electric
fires they can't go out all sorts of
nonsense goes there you
know all sorts of sexual abuse goes
there do you know that what nonsense
goes so the Islamic law even if I agree
how they treat the slave is far superior
than the UN
Charter far superior than
Guantanamo but in
Islam Islam disagrees with having sex
outside the marital bonds so just the
Restriction it was permitted that time
what your right hand possesses but
preferable is as it goes further that
give their freedom in m and affects with
them that's preferable hope that answer
the question thank you sir yes
brother my name is Anand by profession
I'm an interior designer I want to ask
can a Muslim girl marry a non-muslim
boy the brother has a question that can
a Muslim girl marry a non-muslim boy as
I said that a Muslim boy cannot marry a
non-muslim girl until she believes the
same verse I quoted Surah bakar chap 2
verse number 221 says do not marry a
non-believing woman until she believes a
believing woman who's a Bond woman is
far superior to a non-believing woman
even if she allows you the same verse
continues do not marry a non-believing
man a mushrik man until
believes a believing man even if he's a
slave man A bonds man is far superior to
a mushrik man an unbelieving man even if
he allows you he may be the most
handsome man in the world he may be the
wealthiest man in the world but the
believing man is far superior than
unbelieving man so even the vice ver is
the same that a Muslim woman cannot
marry a non-muslim man until he believes
once he accepts Islam then very well she
can marry him the same example of a car
that all the four tires should be same
one of a bicycle and the other of a
truck it will not work because the life
Partners if you really love your wife
you'd want her to go to
Jenna if the Muslim woman loves the
husband she would want the husband to go
to Jenna this life is temporary so
imagine you marry someone and you know
that spouse is going to go to hell so
what's the use so first you get
confirmation that he becomes the Muslim
he agrees as one God and the final
Messengers fori wasam then there are
chances that both will have the best of
this world and the year after hope that
answers the
question anyone on the sister's mic yes
brother hello good evening
sir I'm Sadia Aram uh I'm a first year
student of business management studies
my question is that you said that Muslim
girls are prohibited the professions of
uh acting modeling and uh
dancing does the same apply for men
Muslim men the S as the question that I
said that profession which exhibit the
body like dancing like
modeling film acting is it prohibited
for men also in these cases of film
acting modeling if it goes against the
Quran and Sharia it is prohibited for
example a Muslim man you know models for
some
suit as long as there's nothing Haram in
that ad it's permitted if something
Haram if see models for Black Dog
Whiskey you know or champagne or alcohol
it's
Haram similarly if he's acting if an
acting is showing that he's a non-muslim
doing idol worship it Haram you know
many of the Muslim actors they behave
like non-muslim and they do shik
Haram let him be anyone let him be the
best actor in the
world his acting will take him to
Janam his acting will take him to Janam
but he's acting and doing a good role
not running after women you know running
around trees if all this nonsense is the
hijab is broken it's Haram otherwise
simp thing without any Haram activity
not breaking the hijab following the
Quran and Sunnah making films which are
Islamic which will get a person closer
towards jna to towards Allah subhana
tala it's perfectly fine so as long as
what they doing acting and modeling if
it comes within the perview of the
Islamic Sharia it's permitted otherwi
it's Haram hope to answer the question
thank you sir yes brother assalam
alaykum my question is uh now the age of
uh combined study so is it permitted to
study in field of medical because uh for
womens so because uh most of 99% is we
Face namam brother has a question that
is coeducation permitted especially in
medical colleges correct if a woman
wants to become a doctor and there's no
single sex Medical College is it
permitted if the cause is there the
Islamic Sharia says let a small loss
take place to prevent a big loss so now
that l lady if she goes in a CO College
of Medicine and there's no single sex
College it will be difficult for her to
maintain a hijab but she can she can not
that she can't you know she'll have to
maintain a hijab in medical colleges the
atmosphere is the
worst I've been to a Medical College M
Allah saved
me otherwise Medical College atmosphere
is the worst in terms of breaking the
hijab
worst and and it's only Allah subhana
tala masallah who can save you otherwise
the medical colleges you
know the girls and the
boys they have groups they have to look
examine the patient they stay overnight
it's very
dangerous if Allah is with you inshallah
you can be on the straight path so for a
woman if she goes to a medical college
she has to yet maintain a hijab and in
the college that I was there were Muslim
women who maintain them not all of them
but there were one or two who maintain
the hijab maintain the hijab see to it
that if you have to suppose if the
patient is common and you have to take a
common history with another gent you
know may have to take the common history
of the patient maybe the colleague is a
gent fine when you talk lower your gaze
not oh how are you how is the movie did
you see the movie all common oh let's go
for a spin let's go for a drive on the
bike so all these things if you avoid
and see to it that if you have to talk
with your KH you can talk with lowering
your
gaze though the people will not like it
so she has to maintain a hijab it's very
much possible as for examining the
patient of opposite sex the Quran and
the had give
permission why because you're treating
the patient so doctor can see the
opposite sex if required best is same
sex same doctor best but you don't have
it everywhere that's the reason we
brother
we have initiated in our activities in
the united Islamic Aid a new activity
called as free medical
center so we have started recently which
will inaugurate after this conference sh
Salah the of Majid Nai will be
inaugurating our Center in
mumra on the 10th of November inshallah
two days after the conference the
uniqueness of this Center it
is the uniqueness is it is on the lines
of Quran and Sunnah means lady doctor
will examine lady patients gen doctor
will examine gen patient is the area
2,000 sare ft separate waiting area for
ladies separate for gents children can
go where they want no problem if they
young but lady doctor will check ladies
and inshallah inshallah we aim to have
only mbbs doctors and MD you know so
that they're more professional
everything air condition but free
good quality medicine and inshallah
inshallah when I started the center I'm
a medical doctor I intend to give better
treatment in this free Center than the
own medical clanic that I have
got I've left my profession my brother
and my father mashah they're doctors and
they're running a center which is good
but they we charge that's the bread and
butter we charge money but inshah in
this free medical center inshallah we'll
give better services
inshallah then the own Medical Clinic
that we have for our bed and butter
inshallah fully air condition inshallah
good waiting room hygienic but
free those who can't afford it
free anyone can come even Muslims and
non-muslims can come and in the waiting
room we won't have Stardust magazine we
won't have filare magazine we'll have
Islamic
books we have Islamic satellite channels
you know people have you know you go to
a high caliber doctor FF magazine
Stardust so besides them getting cured
by the diseases inshallah even the IM
will get
cured who Shi it's Allah who
cures so what we believe that if you
want to do medicine if there's no single
sex College you can but you have to
maintain your hijab become a doctor so
that more hijab can be maintained once
that lady doctor becomes muslima becomes
a doctor she will allow many other women
to follow the hijab hope that answer the
question we'll allow only two more
questions one on that mic and the last
question from this mic and we have only
5 minutes left for Dr Zakir to answer
those yes brother alikum uh I am
rewarded my name is uh Abdullah shik
before it was a sushan Kumar mandal I'm
from panil but there's one question
regarding uh Allah
which I always uh I have read the Quran
and I came to know that there is a jat
which I'm trying to go jat directly to
for that I have to follow the Hadi and
Quran but when I read the Hadi and Quran
I came to know that I have to follow
total
sunnat which sunnat has tried to put me
down because of my mother and my mother
asked me to remove my beard my cap and
all Sun
she want me to be like an Indian guy she
says me you have to pray Allah in your
heart not by Salah and there always
Hindu always try to put me like this you
do what what do we say shall I have to
do like this or I have to leave the
house or I have to stay other Mah
brother that's a very good question
Allah gave him hiah he became a Muslim
he realized that following Quran and
Sunnah will give him to Jenna when when
he read the Hadith he followed the
Sunnah he wore a cap he covered his hair
he sported a beard but his mother says
remove the beard remove the cap what
should I do the verses IED of Sur lman
chapter number 31 verse number 14 that
we have enjoyed on the human beings to
be kind to the parents in travel upon
travel did the mother B them but in pain
did she give birth immediately next ver
says Sur lman 31 vers number 15 but if
your parents force you to worship
somebody besides Allah of which you have
no knowledge they do not obey them yet
live with them with love and compassion
the same message repeated in Sur kabud
chapter number 29 verse number 8 we have
enjoined on the human beings to be kind
to the parents but if the parents force
them to do something worship someone
besides Allah of whom they have no
knowledge then don't obey them but yet
live with them with love and compassion
what we realize from Quran and say had
that you have to love your parents you
have to respect them you have to obey
them but if the tell you something
against Allah and his messenger that's
the only time you can disobey them but
yet love them so if they tell you to
remove the beard you tell my dear Mother
our beloved Prophet said it's mentioned
in s bukari Vol number seven in the book
of death Hadith number 780 that do the
opposite of what the pagans do trim your
mustaches and grow the beard I'm
following my messenger and that same
messenger said Paradise Lies Beneath
Your Feet so if I remove the beard even
my Paradise beneath your feet will go
mother I love you mother I care for you
mother I respect you that same Prophet
said that the person that deserves the
best love and compassion is your mother
after that do your mother after that do
your mother so if I stop obeying him I
will have to stop respecting you also
mother I love you I respect you I obey
you as long as you don't go against the
person who's taking to jna that's a
prophet so depending how you speak what
you do if you were not obedient to your
mother before accepting Islam maybe she
told you okay wear a blue color shirt
mother I don't like blue color moment
you became a Muslim mother I will wear a
blue color what happened to my
son before he became a Muslim used to
disobey me now he's obeying me so
whatever your mother told you before you
became a Muslim which you never used to
follow the moment you become a Muslim
start following as long as it doesn't go
against Allah and his you should find a
change start loving her more you have to
respect her suppose she goes to the
temple doing sh is Haram but the moment
she comes out of the temple it becomes
your duty that you take her back home
because you love her because you respect
her even though she's a non-muslim yet
your Paradise Lies Beneath the feet of
your mother your mother may not be in
Paradise but you're Paradise yet Lies
Beneath the feet of a mother love her
respect her obey her until she does not
go against prophet and the see there
should be a change in your life and she
will respect you she will also accept
your religion she'll even accept the
same of prophet wasallam hope the anwers
the
question sir but there is a one problem
is that she has converted into Islam she
accepted my Allah but he's taking in the
uh in the back of Allah she's saying to
me you don't follow what the H
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is giving you
the whole structures of the Islam she is
trying to stop what shall I do I should
leave the house or I should stay away
from my mother because you told me that
in the in the in the feet of mother
there is a j time is running short the
time is running short you have to follow
yet lover with compassion because tell
her that the Quran
say in chapter number 4 verse number 59
so Quran says follow the messenger
therefore I'm following the messenger
not because somebody else is saying so
to follow the Quran I have to follow the
Hadith you love her respect her if she
kicks you out of the house stay out of
the house yet love her thank you sir
thank you
jazak brother we thank all our audience
who has so patiently and consistently
been coming here and stayed so long
inshallah we hope to see you tomorrow
morning for our other programs in the
forthcoming days assalam alaykum
[Music]
oh